während deutschland der atomkraft den
rücken kehrt investieren andere länder
weiter in die kernenergie und es gibt
eine neue deutlich sicherere technik
thorium reaktoren sind sie vielleicht
eine viel einfachere lösung zur
klimaneutralen produktion von energie
wie funktionieren diese reaktoren wie
effizient sind sie und wo liegt der
haken herzlich willkommen bei pixum
science fiction
und danke für den spannenden themen
vorschlag auf whatsapp ein hochaktuelles
thema anders als in gewöhnlichen
kernreaktoren wirtin thorium reaktoren
nicht uran sondern thorium verwendet und
das ist in der erdkruste drei bis
viermal häufiger zu finden als hurra
doch es ist nicht gleich für die
kernspaltung verfügbar denn zunächst
muss es erst einmal in das isotop uran
233 umgewandelt werden das geht durch
die aufnahme eines neutrons und weitere
zwischenstufen in einem atomreaktor das
isotop uran 233 spät besteht aus 92
proton und 141 neutronen lässt sich
super spalten und liefert dabei etwa so
viel energie wie das natürlich
vorkommende uran 235 mit dem
gewöhnlicherweise die nuklear wirtschaft
arbeitet doch der deutliche vorteile des
uran 233 ist das weniger material im
endlager landet denn es entstehen
weniger hoch radioaktive abfälle
der größte teil muss nur noch etwa 300
jahre lang hoch sicher gelagert werden
wow das ist wirklich ein hammer
fortschritt denn neben größten
anzunehmenden unfällen so genannten gaus
oder super gaus wie in japan in
fukushima ist orthomol ja das zweite
riesige und bisher ungelöste problem der
kernenergie
die befürworter werden nicht müde zu
betonen dass thorium reaktoren
energieprobleme weltweit lösen könnten
und dabei sei das risiko noch nicht
einmal besonders hoch im gegenteil denn
in den flüssigkeits reaktoren in dem
thorium verwendet wird das ist dort
nicht fest sondern in einer salz
schmelze gelöst und dies direkt auch für
die kühlung zuständig die visionen waren
deswegen schon immer groß und zum teil
sehen sie es heute noch der physik
nobelpreisträger carlo rubbia hatte
ausgerechnet dass eine tolle story um so
viel energie enthalte wie etwa 200
tonnen uran und das vorkommen reichen
für mehrere jahrtausende doch um solche
thorium reaktoren zu entwickeln wird es
noch einige zeit dauern also diese
sicheren und eine menge geld kosten ja
und wenn es dann so weit ist hätte das
gegebenenfalls fatale folgen für die
welt denn so würden dann nuklearwaffen
auch in ländern verfügbar sein die
politisch und gesellschaftlich eher
instabil sind damit wäre
die schwelle atombombe zu produzieren
viel niedriger und es könnten deutlich
mehr bomben in deutlich mehr ländern
gebaut werden und es wäre auch für
terroristen viel leichter an sie
zukommen indien besitzt zum beispiel
große thorium verkommt und möchten die
kernkraft stark ausbauen um innerhalb
kürzester zeit unabhängiger von uran
importen zu werden auch china ist an
diesem ziel dran insgesamt will die
regierung in peking 3,3 milliarden us
dollar ausgeben um zwei thorium
reaktoren in der wüste gobi zu
entwickeln dazu die south china morning
post
die technologie kann theoretisch mehr
wärme und strom erzeugen als bestehende
form von atomreaktoren
die urahnen verwenden wären sie nur ein
tausendstel der radioaktiven abfälle
produzieren die reaktoren sollen
unterirdisch gebaut werden zwölf
megawatt soll die erzeugte wärme
erreichen die dann zur stromerzeugung
dienen soll aber auch im militärischen
bereich ist diese technologie für china
höchst spannend geplant sind
kriegsschiffe die solche reaktoren in
sich tragen einige experten und
expertinnen warnen schaaf vor der
entwicklung der thorium reaktoren weil
sich so eben auch neuartige atombomben
basteln lesen ja schon im kalten krieg
hatte man herausgefunden dass sich uran
233 hervorragend als bomben stoff eignen
würde somit warnen einige davor dass
thorium reaktoren zur produktion von
waffen material genutzt werden könnten
als eine sorgenfreie atomenergie der
zukunft kann man thorium reaktoren
aufgrund dessen auf gar keinen fall
bezeichnen sie würden die erde zu einem
deutlich unsichereren ort machen wenn er
keine videos zur entwicklung in diesem
bereich und zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann tötet mich bei
whatsapp denn dann verpasst ja absolut
kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
täglich garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken und ihr habt die
unzuverlässige youtube abo box
ausgetrickst und am besten auch meinen
schwesterkanal kriegs um social media
abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus
der social media welt dafür hier klicken
aber nicht die glocke vergessen genau
hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken so wäre ein atomkrieg bis
dann bleibt dran